yeah I gotta get in the studio what's
going on with that Fred wrote a song
it's a hit song for me and Mark Ronson
will be producing with any luck I won't
have to do anything he'll just do it all
even the singing even the singing just
hates me
JD's trying to pitch me he wants a
direct a behind-the-scenes video of this
making of this hit so you've got to let
him well quite honestly I don't hear any
vision with this guy it's like you know
I want to make a documentary like Martin
Scorsese when he did the stones thing he
had a lot going on there this dude
planned it out with cameras dude you got
to give me confidence I don't know that
your work is when I'm done like I think
the music's are sort of been made or
whatever but you know just reporting
that giving the recording process hey
what are you backup what did you say
what's been tsubame like so yeah so
stuff has already been good like I think
there's already like doing beats and
stuff or whatever in other words we're
way into the process there but I thought
it'd be cool to just get like almost
like the studio vibe yeah whatever it's
really good they did they recorded the
black album they had documentarian film
and stuff documentarian talk of my power
so you know Howard's documentarian can
do better no expense I might get on with
some experience but you suggested it I
went there Martin Scorsese and then I
got Martin's score lazy Steven spiel
nerd I just don't see any of the
creative Sparty's yes you're a vision
they only the director would know that
and you want to be the director you got
to propose it and then we take the
budget to like serious I was I just I
brought it up and now it's being brought
up on air so what a pitch I don't know I
brought it up and didn't do another
thing I might call Marty Scorsese and
have JD battle it out let them both make
their pitch like if Marty Scorsese was
gonna make a pitch that the stones he
wouldn't go
I don't know how much the budget I don't
know and I am comfortable I don't mind
this being a camera guy or whatever went
from being the director but now he's
just a grip I actually see like JD makes
a documentary on me making this song and
then we make a documentary following JD
around as he makes the documentary Bay
so we're gonna film the documentary of
JD that's right you really think you
could handle this because if I give you
access I don't want some piece of [ __ ] I
honestly don't know if I could handle it
gives me no confidence what a way to
sell yourself talking Elmo deltar are
called hairs mo very he said I don't
know do it change when he made our first
movie he said I don't know I don't know
am I gonna analyze like I know what I
know
what your boundaries would be or
whatever and I know I'll film it or
whatever action or whatever oh is that
your boundaries
quiet on the shut or something something
like that or whatever do you have any
kind of game plan I gained play whenever
I whatever I hear what all I would be
allowed to tape and stuff so you want to
do it true I'm just gonna follow you
around and then I'll see what the story
is from the footage that's what you say
here's what I can do it unless I can do
it I don't have a vision right now I
think they have no vision but I'll see
what happens Macca mumbly can burn I'm
trying all right I'll get back to you
real quick on that yeah but for
everything's over Howard I wish you
would know a great pitch though I'll
give you that
[Music]
[Music]